bienvenidos de nuevo antes de pasar al
siguiente problema quiero retomar el
problema que estábamos viendo en el
vídeo anterior
muchas veces llego al límite del tiempo
del vídeo y si me excedo de ese límite
de tiempo ya no lo puedo subir a youtube
por lo tanto tengo que hacer las cosas
de manera muy rápida sin embargo me
gustaría que quedara muy claro este
problema y que entendieras por que
llegué a esta conclusión por eso quiero
retomar este problema y fíjate teníamos
cuatro variables que multiplicadas me
daban uno y después teníamos otras
daban cero es más déjenme describirles
aquí mis variables serán s t moon y b de
marca y esto es igual a cero y entonces
yo llegué a la conclusión de que muere
igual a cero y el inciso b pero porque
llegué a esa conclusión a bueno porque
es lo que hice fue observar qué pasaba
con esta ecuación de arriba si te das
cuenta ni él ni ese ítem nivel pueden
ser igual a cero porque si nosotros
multiplicamos algo por cero entonces nos
da la respuesta a cero si alguna de
estas fuera cero entonces nuestra
respuesta sería cero no sería uno por lo
tanto ni r ni ese ítem ni me pueden ser
cero y entonces me fijo en esta ecuación
de abajo que tengo aquí st
muve es igual a cero esto quiere decir
que alguna de estas tiene que ser igual
a cero o sot1 open pero ese no puede ser
cero eso no puede ser cero porque ese
está en esta ecuación de arriba y si
éste fuera cero entonces esto me saldrá
de respuesta cero por lo tanto esa es la
que no puede ser cero la voy a tachar t
de igual manera como está en esta
ecuación no puede ser cero entonces es
una de las variables que no puede ser
igual a cero
ve de vaca le pasa exactamente lo mismo
como está en la ecuación de aquí arriba
no pueden ser 0 tienen que ser algo
distinto de 0 por lo tanto voy a tachar
la también para que te des cuenta que
esta no es la variable que puede ser 0
entonces solamente me queda que muse
igual a 0 común tiene que ser igual a 0
y fue a la conclusión que llegué en el
vídeo pasado que era mi inciso tema
ahora date cuenta que todas las demás
respuestas no pueden ser 0 b no puede
ser 0 porque está en la ecuación de
arriba por otra parte me dicen que te
tiene que ser mayor que un medio es
menor que 1 o en su dado caso ere menor
que 1 sin embargo pues eso no lo puedo
asegurar yo lo único que sentí que puedo
asegurar es que la multiplicación de
estas cuatro variables tiene que ser
igual a 1 ahora pasemos muy rápido al
siguiente problema porque en un examen
de esto necesitamos tener todo el tiempo
posible entonces hay que pasar rápido de
una respuesta a otra muy bien vamos a
hacer otro problema el problema
siguiente que es el problema número 8 el
problema número 8 y que me dice durante
un juego de baloncesto el equipo de
playera azul anotó en total 36 puntos
entonces nuestro equipo tiene playera
así que vamos a agarrar de aquí el color
azul para que tengamos una idea de qué
es lo que va a pasar con nuestro equipo
de playera azul entre todos los
jugadores de playera azul ellos anotaron
en total 36 puntos en un partido de
baloncesto entonces déjame anotarlo aquí
en total metieron 36 puntos entonces
aquí es mi total y metieron 36 puntos
puntos muy bien y bueno de esos 36
puntos en el primer cuarto anotaron un
sexto de la cantidad de puntos totales
entonces en mi primer cuarto en el
cuarto 1 metieron un sexto de la
cantidad de puntos totales muy bien en
el cuarto 2 en el segundo cuarto
anotaron un cuarto de la cantidad de
puntos totales déjame contarlo aquí en
el segundo cuarto anotaron un cuarto de
la cantidad de puntos totales y en el
tercer cuarto anotaron un tercio en el
tercer cuarto anotaron un tercio de la
cantidad de puntos totales muy bien y en
el último cuarto se anotó el resto d
puntos cuántos puntos se anotaron en el
último cuarto entonces lo que quiero
saber es cuántos puntos se notaron en el
último cuarto muy bien ahora para saber
cuántos puntos se anotaron en el último
cuarto qué te parece si lo que
investigamos es cuántos se metieron en
cada uno de los cuartos es decir en el
primer cuarto se metieron un sexto de la
cantidad de puntos totales vamos a ver
cuánto es un sexto de 36 puntos totales
que se metieron y bueno para eso lo que
hay que hacer es multiplicar un sexto
por 36 y bueno esta multiplicación es
muy fácil multiplico uno por 36 me queda
36 entre 6 por 1 y esto me da 6 es decir
36 entre 6 lo cual es 6 en el primer
cuarto se metieron 6 puntos muy bien
ahora en el segundo cuarto se metieron
un cuarto de 2 puntos totales pues vamos
a hacer lo mismo un cuarto por 36 esto
es lo mismo que 36 entre 4 lo cual es 9
puntos en el segundo cuarto se metieron
9 puntos muy bien y en el tercer cuarto
que pasa
cuando se metieron un tercio de la
cantidad de puntos totales entonces un
tercio por 36 esto es igual a 36 entre 3
lo cual es 12 muy bien entonces en el
tercer cuarto se metieron 12 puntos
yo lo que quiero saber es cuántos puntos
se metieron en el último cuarto en el
cuarto cuarto y bueno para esto lo que
voy a hacer es sumar esta cantidad de
puntos y ver cuánto me falta para llegar
a 36 porque en el cuarto cuarto se
metieron y al resto de los puntos
entonces 6 más 9 12
es lo mismo que 27 9 más 12 es 21 6 6 27
36 menos 27 es la cantidad de puntos que
se metieron en el cuarto cuarto y esto
es igual a cuánto esto es igual a 9
puntos por lo tanto ya sé mi respuesta
mi respuesta son 9 puntos que por cierto
es el inciso c de este problema muy bien
ahora vamos a pasar al siguiente
problema entonces déjenme borrar la
pantalla y abrir una nueva perfecto muy
bien problema 9
el problema 9 dice lo siguiente ha dicho
es una ecuación dice que 2 elevado a la
2x esto es igual a 8 elevado a la
x 1 y lo que nos preguntan es el valor
de x lo que quieren saber es cuánto vale
x y bueno hay que resolver esta ecuación
y si te das cuenta es una ecuación que
tiene que ver con exponentes por lo
tanto lo que voy a hacer es recordar las
leyes los exponentes para resolver esta
ecuación sería muy bueno escribir
el 8 de forma que tenga la misma base
que el 2 y para esto hay que recordar
que el 8 es exactamente igual que 2 al
cubo por lo tanto puedo escribir que 2
elevado a la 2 x esto es igual a 808 es
lo mismo que 2 elevado al cubo esto a su
vez elevado a la equis menos 1 esto ha
llevado a la x menos 1 en lugar del 8
estoy poniendo 2 elevado al cubo y bueno
aquí voy a recordar una de las leyes los
exponentes más importantes que hay si no
recuerdas todas las leyes los exponentes
sería muy bueno que revisarán los videos
acerca de exponentes y las ley de los
exponentes que quiero recordar es la que
dice que han elevado a la vez esto a su
vez elevado a una potencia cm
eso es exactamente lo mismo que ha
elevado a la
porsche es decir las potencias pasan
multiplicándose cuando tenemos una base
elevada una potencia elevada una
potencia es decir aquí tengo dos elevado
al cubo elevado a la equis menos uno por
lo tanto las potencias se van a pasar
multiplicando y me va a quedar lo
siguiente déjame cambiar de color no va
a quedar que 2 elevado a la 2 x esto es
igual a 2 elevado a la 3 por x menos 1
es decir 3 x menos 3 3 x x 3 x 3 x menos
uno menos 3 y bueno aquí ya tengo la
misma base cuando tengo la misma base ya
podemos cancelar la base y entonces me
va a quedar solamente una ecuación de
primer grado me va a quedar que 2x es
igual a 3 x menos 32 x es igual a 3 x
menos 3 lo cual ya es muy fácil de
resolver si yo paso este menos 3 x del
otro lado con signo contrario por dicho
de otra manera resto menos 3x de ambos
lados de la ecuación me va a quedar que
menos x es igual a menos 3 y bueno ahora
yo puedo cambiarle a este signo positivo
este signo positivo me va a quedar que x
es igual a tres es decir multiplique
todo por menos uno que por cierto es el
inciso b así que ya tengo otra respuesta
más vamos a borrar la pantalla y vamos a
hacer el siguiente problema el problema
número 10 y para esto ya tenemos que
cambiar de hoja entonces
déjame cambiar de hoja y el problema
número 10 dice lo siguiente y veamos qué
dice el problema 10
el problema 10 dice wow es uno de los
típicos problemas en los cuales hay que
pasar del español al lenguaje matemático
así que para no hacer este vídeo más
largo déjame ver si puedo copiar y pegar
esta oración que tenemos aquí y ya está
perfecto dice sí tres veces un ciertos
números menos cuatro es igual a dos más
ese mismo número de que el número
estamos hablando y bueno lo primero que
vamos a intentar hacer es pasar al
lenguaje matemático entonces dice sí
tres veces un cierto número a este
cierto número de una vez vamos a ponerle
nombre a este cierto número le voy a
llamar x entonces sí tres veces x menos
cuatro es igual a dos más ese mismo
número pero ese mismo número ya tiene
nombre ese mismo número se llama x
entonces es igual a 2 más x de qué
número estamos hablando y lo que nos
preguntan es el número
es decir x yo lo que quiero saber es
cuánto vale x y bueno para esto vamos a
escribir esta oración en una ecuación y
vamos a ver si lo podemos hacer que
tengo aquí dice si tres veces un cierto
número tres veces un cierto número pues
esto lo mismo que ese número
multiplicado por tres porque le voy a
tomar tres veces esto de aquí significa
3x entonces si tres veces un cierto
número es decir 3x menos 4 a eso está
muy fácil menos 4 pues es solamente a
esto quitarle 4 esto me dice que es
igual a 2 + ese mismo número 2 pues es
el 2 que nosotros conocemos fácil
sencillo entonces este 2 más es lo mismo
que dos más ese mismo número pero ese
mismo número ya tiene nombre entonces es
más equis y yo lo que quiero saber es el
valor de x y ya pasamos de esta oración
a un lenguaje matemático y si te das
cuenta es una ecuación muy fácil de
resolver es una ecuación de primer grado
entonces para resolver esta ecuación lo
que voy a hacer primero es pasar esta x
del otro lado de la ecuación y la voy a
pasar con signo contrario es decir voy a
restar x ambos lados de la ecuación de
tal manera que aquí me va a quedar 3 x x
lo cual es 2 x menos 4 esto es igual a 2
más x menos x es decir esta x se va y
ahora voy a pasar este 4 del otro lado
de la ecuación con signo positivo y para
eso lo que voy a hacer es sumar 4 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me va a
quedar que 2 x este 4 se va a pasar para
acá es igual a 2 + 4 lo cual es
muy bien y ahora voy a dividir todo
entre 2 para obtener el valor de x es de
2 10 de 12 van y me queda que x es igual
a 6 entre 2 lo cual es 3 perfecto ya
tengo la respuesta correcta de este
problema que por cierto era el inciso iv
y bueno aquí acabo este vídeo para ya no
hacer otro problema con toda la presión
del tiempo ya no te quito más tiempo y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo